il est
le trottoir
le long de l'église
curé
oui
elle avait maintenant il
de grandry
une vertu
bon ce temps là
j'allais à confesse
tous les mercredis à de 7h15
et
j'étais le dernier
à part les deux pays
et si j'ai pensé
arasa
deux des sonneurs
dans le cas
ce mercredi là
jeu plaisant m'avance
j'avais des artères
le français
et jallet marais
la conscience quand j'ai entendu
qui au piquet
gonzague de francs
un coup d'oeil
j'étais le seul bic est à cent lieues
autour
alors j'ai suivi
ça m'a pris
je voulais me perdre
j'ai perdu
ceux-là
comme promis
et c'est la mé ment
en sept changements obscur et
chambre sans joie sans fleurs
c'est là que j'ai reçu
revenir de blessure
le c'est mon enfant
de menton
on
peut rêver
pour sa grande première
le coucher de soleil
de chance muc
moi je vais récolter
votre père
depuis le 12 mars
jérôme français
de même nous en sommes en paix
dans mon cas
le jeu
nous allons
non